- ALL RIGHT, MAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY, JUST LET’S
SETTLE DOWN AND SETTLE IN
AND, LIKE, TOTALLY LET’S GET
OUR MATH ON, OKAY?
ALL RIGHT, GUYS, SO--
YEAH, OH!
ALL RIGHT, JIMMY,
SOMEONE’S GOT A LITTLE EXTRA
ENERGY FROM PHYS ED, RIGHT?
JIMMY, BUDDY, HEY,
BUDDY, LET’S--OKAY, LET’S--
LET’S KNOCK IT OFF, OKAY?
OKAY.
- HE WANTED ME
TO KNOCK IT OFF...
- YOU GOT ME.
HE GOT ME, RIGHT, GUYS?
- SO I KNOCKED IT OFF.
- JIMMY, DUDE, ALL RIGHT,
LET’S TAKE OUR SEAT.
- TAKE OUR SEAT.
WELL, HEY, HEY.
- THAT’S GREAT.
THAT’S GREAT.
- [robot noises]
- VERY GOOD.
BRAVO, JIMMY.
YOU GUYS CAN CLAP.
- YAY!
- THAT WAS AWESOME.
OH, I THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU
FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT, MAN.
- [gibbering]
JIMMY--LET’S GO, MAN.
HEY, BUDDY--I DON’T WANT
TO HARSH YOUR VIBE, MAN, BUT--
- AH, EUREKA.
- I’M GONNA BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
YOU’RE REALLY PUSHING
MY BUTTONS NOW, JIMMY.
- [beeping electronically]
YOU’RE DRIVING ME CRAZY, MAN.
- [zooming]
[imitating a car]
- THAT’S ENOUGH.
YOU WANT ME TO WRITE
YOUR NAME ON THE BOARD?
- [yells]
HOME ALONE,
HOME ALONE, HOME ALONE.
- OKAY, JIMMY, DO YOU WANT ME
TO CALL PRINCIPAL MARTEL?
- [gasping]
- THAT’S ENOUGH, JIMMY.
- [chattering]
- OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, JIMMY?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY DON’T YOU COME UP
AND TEACH THE CLASS, MAN?
HMM?
WOULDN’T THAT BE AWESOME?
- MOI?
- OKAY, GOOD.
NO, AND THEN YOU KNOW WHAT
I’M GONNA DO, JIMMY?
I’LL JUST SIT HERE.
HOW ’BOUT THAT, JIMMY,
AND WE CAN ALL WATCH HOW
YOU’RE BEING DISRUPTIVE--
- [speaks nonsense]
- OH, I SEE.
THAT’S SUPPOSED TO BE ME.
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
JIMMY, OKAY, I SEE.
I GET IT’S SUPPOSED TO BE ME.
IT’S TIME TO BE DONE, JIMMY.
DON’T YOU DARE, JIMMY.
WHAT THE--
[scissors snip]
OH, YEAH?
[unintelligible scream]
WELL, THIS IS YOU, JIMMY!
[screaming nonsense]
I’M YOU, JIMMY!
[screams nonsense]
[growling and screaming]
HOW ’BOUT THAT, JIMMY, HUH?
"OH, I’M GONNA SLAP FIVE!
GIVE ME FIVE!"
GIVE ME--GIVE ME FIVE!
HUH, HOW ’BOUT THAT, HUH?
THAT’S YOU, JIMMY!
"I’M JIMMY.
"I’M JIMMY,
AND I NEED ATTENTION!
"YEAH, I’M JIMMY! I’M JIMMY!
"OH, LOOKIE HERE.
I’M A BABY BOY.
"THAT’S THE FUNNIEST THING
"THAT EVER HAPPENED
IN THE WHOLE WORLD!
"I’M JIMMY!
I WANT ATTENTION!
"WIGGY, WIGGY, WIGGY,
WIGGY, WIGGY, WIGGY!
I’M JIMMY!
I’M JIMMY!"
[high-pitched gibberish]
- MR. FRIAR!
- PRINCIPAL MARTEL!
NO, WHAT?
NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, IT WAS JIMMY.
IT WAS JIMMY, PRINCIPAL MARTEL.
NO, JIMMY--
IT WAS JIMMY!
- WHOO!
[all cheering]
- JIMMY!
all: JIMMY, JIMMY, JIMMY,
JIMMY, JIMMY, JIMMY,
JIMMY, JIMMY, JIMMY, JIMMY,
JIMMY, JIMMY,
JIMMY, JIMMY, JIMMY,
[cheering]